sup everyone so my name is Chun and I
was reading some of the comments you
guys posted last time from Davis video
and you guys say that's kind of cute I'm
really flattered I don't really know
what to say kind of new to this stuff
chut Thank You funny huh this is because
I don't you know what no you think it
huh huh just over and don't go so online
okay you know money it's my birthday I
know what your birthday you're just
you're not giving me a second thought
just give me a sec the top okay so I'm
making this video for you for them to
tell them that your birthday and I even
got you something hold on oh yeah I got
you some fruit snacks man
see I got your fruit snacks umi-chan pop
just like the gumbo I'll meet you I
don't need a capo any of this you know
what oh what's going on YouTube
first of all thank you for the birthday
wishes it's not birthday or it was my
birthday and now I am I am a certain age
oh I just got invited to Eva Sonya
somebody's house holla
only five people dance when you think
about food you guys have been leaving
some of the craziest comments and I
gotta say you think I'm funny you guys
are hilarious but there are certain
lines that are drawn when you guys leave
comments and when the compliments is
cool but there are certain things that
you should say or maybe phrase in a
certain way
for example that Alexander Wallace girl
was so wrong thanks for making a bad
situation into something we can laugh
about that's a good thing something you
shouldn't say seriously I do have my
samurai sword don't worry David we can
go to jail just the two of us yeah
things you can't say you're cute marry
me things you shouldn't say you're cute
holla at me sugar tits and I'm not
talking about Alexandra Wallace either
[ __ ] why the worst part about this
comment wasn't about what the person
said it was the fact that when I clicked
the username it was a man and on top of
that the dude was wearing a pink sweater
vest with a lollipop in his mouth
oh but anyways you guys wanted me to do
a vlog about Rebecca Black and I'm sorry
YouTube I can't do that because she's a
13 year old girl and as a 13 year old
girl I can't I can't get mad at her she
made a song about something that doesn't
make sense for [ __ ] cuz she's 13 but you
expect I mean the only person that I've
got to make fun of in that video is that
random ass brother that came out and
started rapping like who is how low has
your rap career gone that you had to
start rapping in a Rebecca black video
[Music]
driving Suzie I heard you got called the
feta sure that's not right he doesn't
look like feta she looks like he's ugly
cousin or something for those of you
ladies who have been hitting on the
gobball through my page sorry ladies he
has a girlfriend
chocolate thunder stone black he Snipes
is taking turn me on the other hand he
is single and for those of you ladies
who want to get in contact with him his
phone number is
[Music]
well you know Serbia this is vlog number
seven I'm gob oh I'm done and I'm sorry
David couldn't make it today but we got
that new video for all you video lovers
out there
David so calm I'm done with this you
know what I'm telling yo ass I'm time yo
add this little Jackie Chan little
cristela thing it's over there you know
what you think I'm scared of you cuz you
got muscles ha let's just make you mad
[ __ ]
guess we'll see you come around here do
it again [ __ ] not get out that's what
huh